mr speaker let me set out the three
elements of the strengthened end-to-end
system for international arrivals
coming into force on 15th of february
this new system is for
england and we're working on similarly
tough schemes with the devolved
administrations
and working with the irish government to
put in place a similar as
a system that works across the common
travel area
the three parts are as follows hotel
quarantine
testing and enforcement first mr speaker
we're setting up a new system of hotel
quarantine for uk
and irish residents who've been in red
list countries in the last 10 days
in short this means that any returning
residents from these countries
will have to quarantine in an assigned
hotel room
for 10 days from the time of arrival
before they travel they'll have to book
through an online platform
and pay for a quarantine package costing
1
750 pounds for an individual traveling
alone
which includes the hotel transport and
testing
this booking system will go live on
thursday when we'll also publish the
full
detailed guidance passengers will only
be able to enter the uk
through a small number of ports that
currently account for the vast majority
of passenger arrivals
when they arrive they'll be escorted to
a designated hotel
which will be closed to guests who
aren't quarantining for 10 days
or for longer if they test positive for
covid19
during their stay we've contracted 16
hotels for an in
an initial 4600 rooms and we will secure
more
as they are needed people will need to
remain in their rooms and of course will
not be allowed to mix with other guests
and they'll be visible security in place
to ensure compliance alongside necessary
support so even as we protect public
health we can look after the people in
our care
second mr speaker we're strengthening
testing
all passengers are already required to
take a pre-departure test
and cannot travel to this country if it
is positive
from monday all international arrivals
whether under home quarantine
or hotel quarantine will be required by
law to take
further pcr tests on day two
and day eight of that quarantine
passengers will have to book these tests
through our online
portal before they travel anyone
planning to travel
to the uk from monday needs to book
these tests
and the online portal will go live on
thursday
if either of these post arrival tests
comes back positive
they'll have to quarantine for a further
10 days from the date of the test
and will of course be offered any nhs
treatment that's necessary
any positive result will automatically
undergo genomic sequencing
to confirm whether they have a variant
of concern
under home quarantining the existing
test release scheme which my right-hand
friend the transport secretary has built
so effectively
can still be used from day five but this
will be in addition to the two mandatory
tests
the combination of enhanced testing and
sequencing
has been a powerful weapon through this
pandemic and we'll be bringing it to
bear so we can find positive cases
break the chains of transmission and
prevent new cases and new variants from
putting us at risk
third mr speaker we'll be backing this
new system with strong enforcement of
both home quarantine
and hotel quarantine people who flout
these rules
are putting us all at risk passenger
carriers will have a duty in law
to make sure that passengers have signed
up for these new arrangements before
they travel
and will be fined if they don't and
we'll be putting in place tough fines
for people who don't comply
this includes a 1 000 pound penalty for
any international arrival who fails to
take a mandatory test
a 2 000 pound penalty to any
international arrival who fails to take
the second mandatory test
as well as automatically extending their
quarantine period to 14 days
and a 5 000 pound fixed penalty notice
rising to 10 000
for arrivals who failed to quarantine in
a designated hotel
we're also coming down hard on people
who provide false information on the
passenger
locator form anyone who lies on the
passenger locator form
and tries to conceal that they've been
in a country on the red list
in the 10 days before arrival here will
face a prison sentence
of up to 10 years these measures will be
put into law
this week and i've been working with the
home secretary the border force and the
police to make sure the resources
more resources are being put into
enforcing these measures
i make no apologies for the strength of
these measures
because we're dealing with one of the
strongest threats to our public health
that we've faced as a nation
i know that most people have been doing
their bit
making huge sacrifices as part of the
national effort
and these new enforcement powers will
make sure their hard work and sacrifice
isn't undermined by a small minority who
don't want to follow the rules
mr speaker in short we're strengthening
the health protection at the border in
three crucial ways
hotel quarantine for uk and irish
residents who visited a
redless country in the past 10 days and
home quarantine for all passengers
from any other country a three-test
regime for all arrivals
and firm enforcement of pre-departure
tests and the passenger locator form
our fight against this virus has many
fronts
and just as we're attacking this virus
through our vaccination program which is
protecting more people each day
we're buttressing our defenses against
these vital measures
so we can protect the progress that
we've worked together
so hard to accomplish and i commend this
statement to the house